¿No es increíble cuánto control
pueden conseguir los atacantes con tan solo una simple operación?
Les mostraré cómo la mayoría de malware
cómo se distribuye hoy.
Lo que haré es abrir un sitio web
que escribí.
Es un sitio terrible. Tiene gráficos realmente horribles.
Y tiene una sección de comentarios aquí
donde nosotros podemos publicar comentarios a la página web.
Muchos de Uds. habrán usado antes algo de esto.
Desafortunadamente, cuando se implementó,
el desarrollador estaba un poco ebrio
y consiguió olvidar
todas las prácticas de codificación seguras que había aprendido.
Entonces imaginemos que nuestro atacante,
llamado Pirata Malvado solo por valor cómico,
inserta algo un poco desagradable.
Este es un script.
Es el código que se reproduce en la página web.
Así que enviaré este correo,
y luego, en la computadora de mi víctima,
abriré el navegador web
e iré a mi sitio web,
www.incrediblyhacked.com.
Vean que después de un par de segundos,
me redirecciona.
La dirección del sitio web en la parte superior
que solo puede ver, microshaft.com,
el navegador se bloquea mientras golpea uno de estos paquetes explosivos
y aparece un antivirus falso.
Este es un virus que hace como si fuere software antivirus,
analizará y escaneará el sistema,
miren lo que está apareciendo aquí.
Crea algunas alertas muy serias.
Miren, un servidor proxy para porno infantil.
Realmente deberíamos limpiar esto.
Lo que es muy insultante acerca de esto es
que no solo proporcionan a los atacantes acceso a sus datos,
sino que, cuando la exploración termina, dicen
con el fin de limpiar los virus falsos,
Ud. tiene que registrar el producto.
Me gustaba más cuando los virus eran gratis.
(Risas)
La gente ahora paga a los ciberdelincuentes dinero
para ejecutar los virus,
lo que me parece totalmente extraño.
De todos modos, déjenme cambiar de ritmo un poco.
Perseguir 250 000 piezas de malware al día
es un desafío enorme,
y esos números no hacen más que crecer
directamente en proporción a la longitud de la línea de mi estrés, como Uds. podrán ver aquí.
Así que quiero hablarles brevemente
acerca de un grupo de piratas a los que rastreamos durante un año
y pillamos...
y esto es una suerte inusual en nuestro trabajo.
Esto fue una colaboración intersectorial,
de gente de Facebook, investigadores independientes,
tipos de Sophos.
Aquí tenemos un par de documentos
que habían subido los ciberdelincuentes
para un servicio en la nube, como Dropbox o SkyDrive,
como muchos de Uds. quizá usan.
En la parte superior, Uds. verán una sección de código fuente.
Lo que haría es enviar a los ciberdelincuentes
un mensaje de texto cada día diciéndoles cuánto dinero
habían hecho ese día,
así una especie de informe de facturación ciberdelictivo.
Si se fijan bien, notarán una serie
que corresponde a números de teléfono rusos.
Ahora eso es obviamente interesante,
porque nos da una pista de cómo encontrar a los ciberdelincuentes.
Abajo, resaltado en rojo,
en la otra sección del código fuente,
está este "leded:leded".
Es el nombre de un usuario,
como el que quizá se tenga en Twitter.
Así que veremos esto un poco más a fondo.
Hay otras piezas interesantes
que habían subido los ciberdelincuentes.
Muchos de Uds. aquí usarán teléfonos inteligentes
para tomar fotos de la conferencia y publicarlas.
Una característica interesante de muchos de los teléfonos inteligentes modernos
es que al tomar la foto,
incrusta datos del GPS sobre dónde se hizo la foto.
De hecho, he pasado mucho tiempo
visitando sitios de citas en Internet,
obviamente para fines de investigación,
y me he dado cuenta de que aproximadamente el 60 %
de las fotos de perfil en los sitios de citas por Internet
contienen las coordenadas GPS de donde se hizo la foto,
que da un poco de miedo
porque no le darías tu dirección
a un montón de extraños,
pero estamos muy contentos de dar las coordenadas de GPS
con una precisión de más o menos 15 metros.
Y nuestros ciberdelincuentes habían hecho lo mismo.
Así que aquí hay una foto realizada en San Petersburgo.
Luego desplegamos la herramienta de piratería increíblemente avanzada.
Utilizamos Google.
Utilizando la dirección de correo electrónico, el número de teléfono
y los datos del GPS, a la izquierda verán un anuncio
para un BMW que vende uno de los ciberdelincuentes.
En el otro lado hay un anuncio para vender gatitos sphynx.
Uno de estos me parecía demasiado estereotipado.
Algo más de búsqueda y aquí está nuestro ciberdelincuente.
Imaginen, estos son ciberdelincuentes endurecidos
apenas compartiendo información.
Imaginen lo que uno podría descubrir
sobre cada una de las personas en esta sala.
Buscando un poco más a través del perfil
se ve una foto de su oficina.
Trabajaban en el tercer piso.
Y también pueden ver algunas fotos
de su compañero de negocios
donde él aporta una prueba en un imagen concreta.
Se trata de un miembro de la Federación Rusa de Webmasters para Adultos.
Pero aquí es donde nuestra investigación comienza a ralentizarse.
Los ciberdelincuentes han cerrado sus perfiles bastante bien.
Y aquí está la lección más grande
de las redes sociales y dispositivos móviles para todos nosotros ahora mismo.
Nuestros amigos, nuestras familias y nuestros colegas
pueden violar nuestra seguridad aun haciendo las cosas bien.
Se trata de MobSoft, una de las empresas
perteneciente a esta pandilla del cibercrimen,
y una cosa interesante sobre MobSoft
es que el dueño del 50 % de la empresa
publicó un anuncio de trabajo,
y este anuncio de trabajo correspondía a uno de los números de teléfono
en el código anterior.
Esta mujer es María,
y María es la esposa de uno de los ciberdelincuentes.
Y es así como entró en su configuración de las redes sociales
y hago clic en cualquiera de las opciones imaginables
para ponerse realmente, en una situación insegura.
Al final de la investigación,
donde se puede leer el informe completo de 27 páginas en ese vínculo,
tenemos fotos de los ciberdelincuentes,
incluso de la fiesta de Navidad en la oficina
o cuando estuvieron de excursión.
Y es verdad, los ciberdelincuentes celebran fiestas de Navidad,
como se ve.
Ahora se preguntarán qué pasó con estos muchachos.
Déjenme volver a ello en un minuto.
Quiero cambiar el ritmo con una última demostración,
una técnica que es muy simple y básica,
pero es interesante exponer cuánta información
regalamos todos,
y es relevante porque es aplicable a nosotros como audiencia de TED.
Esto sucede cuando la gente empieza a hurgar en los bolsillos
tratando de cambiar en modo avión en el teléfono desesperadamente.
Muchos de Uds. saben sobre el concepto
de buscar redes inalámbricas.
Lo hacemos cada vez que sacamos el iPhone o el Blackberry
y que nos conectamos a TEDAttendees, por ejemplo.
Pero lo que quizá no saben
es que también envían información de la lista de redes
a las que se hayan conectado previamente
incluso aun cuando no usen la red inalámbrica activamente.
Así que hice un pequeño análisis.
Estaba relativamente limitado en comparación con los ciberdelincuentes,
que no se preocupan tanto por la ley,
y aquí pueden ver mi dispositivo móvil.
¿De acuerdo? ¿Pueden ver una lista de redes inalámbricas.
TEDAttendees, HyattLB. ¿Dónde creen que me hospedo?
Mi red doméstica, PrettyFlyForAWifi,
creo que es un nombre fantástico.
Sophos_Visitors, SANSEMEA, las empresas con la que trabajo.
Loganwifi, que se encuentra en Boston. HiltonLondon.
CIASurveillanceVan.
Lo llamamos así en una de nuestras conferencias
porque pensamos que podría asustar a la gente
lo que es muy divertido.
Esto es como una fiesta de frikis.
Pero hagamos esto un poco más interesante.
Hablemos de Uds.
23 % de Uds. estuvieron en Starbucks
recientemente y utilizaron la red inalámbrica.
Las cosas se ponen más interesantes.
A 46 % de Uds. yo los podría vincular a su empresa.
Red de empleados de XYZ.
Esto no es una ciencia exacta, pero consigue bastante precisión.
Identifiqué que 761 de Uds. habían estado recientemente en un hotel
absolutamente con precisión milimétrica en algún lugar en el mundo.
Sé dónde viven 234 de Uds.
Su nombre de red inalámbrica es tan único
que fui capaz de identificarlo
utilizando datos disponibles abiertamente en Internet
sin pirateos ni trucos sofisticados e inteligentes.
Y debo mencionar también
algunos de Uds. usan sus nombres,
"IPhone de James Lyne", por ejemplo.
Y 2 % de Uds. tienen una tendencia extrema a lo profano.
Algo en lo que Uds. deberían pensar:
Al incorporar el uso de estas nuevas aplicaciones y dispositivos móviles,
y al jugar con estos nuevos juguetes brillantes,
¿cuánto privacidad y seguridad
arriesgamos para nuestra conveniencia?
La próxima vez que instalen algo,
miren la configuración y pregúntense,
"¿Es la información que quiero compartir?
¿Alguien podría utilizarla indebidamente?"
También tenemos que pensar con precaución
cómo podemos desarrollar nuestro futuro talento.
Ya ven, la tecnología cambia a una velocidad asombrosa,
y las 250 000 piezas de malware
no serán las mismas por mucho tiempo.
Hay una tendencia muy preocupante,
que muchas personas que acaban la escuela
saben mucho de tecnología, saben cómo usar la tecnología,
pero menos y menos personas están al tanto del proceso
para saber cómo funciona la tecnología entre bambalinas.
En el Reino Unido, una reducción del 60 % desde el 2003,
y hay estadísticas similares en todo el mundo.
También tenemos que pensar en los problemas legales en este ámbito.
Los ciberdelincuentes de los que hablé,
a pesar del robo de millones de dólares,
en realidad todavía no han sido arrestados,
y a este punto, posiblemente nunca lo serán.
La mayoría de las leyes se implementan a nivel nacional,
a pesar de los convenios de ciberdelincuencia, donde Internet
es internacional por definición y sin fronteras.
Los países no están de acuerdo en abordar esta cuestión
excepcionalmente difícil desde una perspectiva jurídica.
Pero mi pregunta más amplia es:
Uds. saldrán de aquí
y verán algunas historias asombrosas en las noticias.
Leerán sobre el malware que hace
cosas increíbles, aterradoras e intimidantes.
Sin embargo, el 99 % de esto funciona
porque la gente falla en hacer lo básico.
Entonces mi pregunta es: ya en línea,
encuentren las mejores prácticas sencillas,
averigüen cómo actualizar y reparar su computadora.
Obtengan una contraseña segura.
Asegúrense de utilizar una contraseña diferente
en cada uno de sus sitios y servicios en línea.
Encuentren estos recursos. Aplíquenlos.
Internet es un recurso fantástico
para los negocios, para la expresión política,
para el arte y para el aprendizaje.
Contribuyan a una comunidad segura
hagan la vida mucho, mucho más difícil
a los ciberdelincuentes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)